16 here's some support for the young
entrepreneur in your house a local
author has published a book on the world
of business in and of itself amazing
he's 12. so how can other kids get
involved in business Lauren Grady
joining us live this morning with his
story and some tips to get started
Lauren good morning
good morning yes it is phenomenal his
name is Rico Cruz here 12 year old
business CEO he has his candied puffcorn
snack business he wrote a book detailing
about how it got started and now he's
going to give two thousand dollars to go
on a book tour and bring his savviness
there to Clark County School Districts
for workshops there next year but you
can get involved right now with his free
startup Kids Camp sign up now through
June 3rd the three-day event is June 27
through the 29th at the Nevada Partners
the kids learn about developing their
business Vision their elevator pitch and
their financial literacy and networking
and advertising all resources very
necessary
I hope young African-American kids get
inspired to one start their own business
and to get the reference that they can
do whatever they want as long as they
put their mind to it
thank you
know they hold their business boot camp
there ahead of the different event in
July it's called their young Biz kid day
which is a youth marketplace with more
than 30 kids CEOs selling their products
Rico has some advice there a service is
usually easier say you're a Dancer come
up with your elevator pitch why someone
should want to do your class nail down a
marketing plan and then think about your
customer as well and again he details
all that more on his website here too
Rico's Rockin pop and that should be a
great event live in The Newsroom Lauren
negretti 8 news now Mary Jane over to
you